bonjour il a fait déjà beaucoup de monde
et plusieurs dizaines d'interpellations
[Musique]
effectivement sophie serait que l'appel
à manifestation de jérôme dans la glaise
été entendu son nom plusieurs centaines
de personnes ici place wagram alors j'ai
roulé gaza appelait en léger les jeunes
ici sans pièce d'identité pour dit-il
saturer les capacité d'interpellation
des policiers d'ailleurs cet appel à la
désobéissance civile a été qualifié de
puérile 1 par le préfet de police dit
également alors jérôme rodez gaza qui
est au coeur de la polémique depuis
plusieurs jours après avoir comparé les
policiers à des nazis s'est exprimé à
nos micros il estime que finalement la
réaction du ministère de l'intérieur qui
veut porter plainte après ces propos de
la suite de cette figure des gilet jaune
est une façon de jeu le site créé un bad
buzz pour faire oublier les vrais
problèmes des français et écoutez quoi
aller nous traitent comme des enfants la
défaite du magic phil mais découle de l
bd coûte j'ai pas de leçon à recevoir
chez monsieur d'accord face aux propos
qui peut tenir en face et aux actions
qui peut mener
je suis pas là pour parler de lui on est
là pour parler des revendications on est
là pour parler des filets jaunes on est
là pour parler des gens qui sont dans la
souffrance de ceux qui vont basculer sur
le marché de la misère
de toutes ces personnes aujourd'hui en
colère on est là pour parler de dieu
alors je suis fatigué de parler de
violences de parler de petit bad buzz de
plein de partis et d'autres conneries
par là et de jean marie meyer comme ça
lassé sont ces gens là qui sont
intéressantes
c'est avec lui qu'il faut discuter il ya
plein de gens qui ont des choses à dire
il ya plein de petits patrons l'appelant
d'employés voilà il ya la france en
colère initialement elle et manifestants
s'étaient donné rendez vous à 9 heures
sur les champs-elysées mais impossible
d'y accéder
face à une présence policière très
importante ils se sont dirigés vers la
place de wagram alors pour l'instant ici
l'ambiance est plutôt festive les jeux
les jeunes se réjouissant d'être aussi
ici alors la préfecture de police et son
côté signale qu'il ait fallu 68
interpellations et du cette
verbalisation depuis le début de la
matinée
si beaucoup les larmes aux yeux et on
vous retrouvera évidemment tout au long
de cette journée poursuivre avec vous ce
rassemblement un des jeux les jeux